foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight up is working on censored sleaze
and Scandal rocks British politics again
how can we trust our leaders to fix a
world in crisis when we can't even trust
them to follow their own laws
and while Germany Dithers Britain and
America sent tanks to Ukraine and say
more help is on his way but as a warning
is it's blood-soaked anniversary good
arming Ukraine now be escalating it I'll
debate that with a man dub Putin's
number one enemy
because what our village says trans
women can continue to compete against
women I'll talk exclusively to the
British champion who says women's sport
is under attack
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening Fernando welcome to
Piers Morgan on sensitive millions of
people are understandably worried about
the amount of money in their bank
accounts right now our leaders should be
worrying about that too instead well yet
again preoccupied with the amount of
money in their bank accounts and how it
got there Boris Johnson secured an 800
000 pound loan guarantee with the help
of Richard Sharp a man he then made
chairman of the BBC just Weeks Later the
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi paid five million pounds to
settle a tax dispute including a one
million pound fine for carelessness this
while he was the chancellor in charge of
the entire country's finances we don't
need formal investigations to tell us
what this all smells of it smells of
more of the Scandal and sleaze there's
beset the conservative government in the
last few years and yet we were promised
so much different after three years of
disorder and deceit under Boris Johnson
which is sunac said we get a clean break
this is what he said and his first
speech as prime minister
I will work day in and day out to
deliver for you
this government
will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
Trust
is earned and I will earn yours
right well it's not going very well is
it Rishi
he's now asked his new ethics advisor
and you're needing one of those if
you're running the country to formally
investigate Mr zahawi but frankly I
think he's got enough on his plate
already in zahari's case doesn't need
any formal inquiries this is all very
straightforward the prime minister to
sit down with him and say did you lie to
me
yes or no if you did you're out
and Mr zahami needs to tell us exactly
what's going on here with his finances
he's a very wealthy man who appears to
be rather unclean on paying his full tax
let's see if he wants to question what I
just said let's see the evidence
one of my New Year's promises to you was
to grow the economy and today we're
announcing the second round of
allocations from our leveling up fund
now that might seem trivial Richie soon
act caught not wearing a seatbelt it is
Trivial by comparison to the other stuff
I've mentioned it's trivial of calls to
the cost of living crisis and of course
to the Raging war in Ukraine and many
other things but it is a fact that our
prime minister has now been fined twice
once this Chancellor wants his PM
Britain went 300 years without a prime
minister breaking my law in office now
we're two in a year
meanwhile across the pond in America
former president Trump faces a criminal
investigation into classified documents
at his Florida estate which sent
Democrats into spasms of condemnation
until guess what classified documents
turned up in President Biden's office
home and garage and tonight we've got
breaking news that vice president Pence
Trump's number two has also discovered
classified documents in his home is
there any American Senior politician
president or vice president who has not
been taking illegally classified
documents back home to their garage
so everywhere you look from Britain to
America across the vast Atlantic suede
of the special relationship there's
sleaze and Scandal and people at the top
who just don't think the rules need to
apply to them
what I want politicians to be focusing
on right now
is the devastating war in Ukraine
and the worst cost living crisis in a
generation today I would say ominously
the Doomsday Clock moved 10 seconds
closer to midnight that means the
world's smartest people now think we are
90 seconds away from a literal end of
the world from Armageddon
that sounds quite serious because it is
quite serious so it's probably our time
that our politicians also got very
serious but how can we trust them to fix
a world in crisis when we can't even
trust them to follow the laws that they
make
well join me now it's former
conservative Minister Ann whittakam
reform UK lead and talk to you presenter
Richard Tice lawyer and talkatively
contributor Paula Roan Adrian and from
America uh Fox News presenter Steve
Hilton there was of course chief of
strategy to former Prime Minister of
Great Britain David Cameron welcome to
all of you Steve great to have you
making your debut on Piers Morgan
uncensored uh what do you what do you
make of all this sitting over there in
the leafy confines of warm balmy
California when you look back at your
old uh motherland here what do you make
of this absolutely Relentless tidal wave
of sleeves and Scandal that has really
engulfed us yeah from Boris Johnson to
Liz trust now Rishi signet's government
what do you make of it all
well it's embarrassment all round and I
completely agree with where you ended
which is these people need to get
serious that is what politics and
serving in government is supposed to be
about but actually you know the some of
the cliches that people use when they
talk about politicians and they say oh
they're all the same they're all in it
for themselves increasingly that turns
out to be the case when you look at this
generation they seem to be this arrogant
out of touch ruling Elite that aren't
focused on the Practical things people
want to get done and it's such a
contrast with an earlier generation and
Anne will remember this as well I mean
in my time when I was working in number
um I thought about the just this just
the other week when we got the news that
Lord young died in December great man
Lord young and I worked very closely
with him in number 10 on a bunch of
policy issues to do with advancing
Enterprise and helping small business
and so on and there's a few others like
that people like Lord Hessel time like
Kenneth Baker that I worked with very
closely on a range of policy things now
whatever you think of those people their
politics or their personalities what was
really interesting to me was that they
just wanted to get things done on the
issues that they cared about they didn't
want any Glory they didn't want endless
meetings with David Cameron they were
just interested in making things happen
in a practical way and that sense of
real Public Service it just seems to be
disappearing yeah I think that's
absolutely spot-on and Whitaker you'd be
grimacing you've been gesticulating off
you go I don't think I was gesticulating
but I was certainly grimacing when you
said that Nadeem was unkeen to pay his
taxes well he didn't pay it
you can't correct a fact what can you I
didn't say that I said he may not
necessarily have been un Keen now you
know there is if you're Keen to pay your
taxes
yes if you know that you owe them if you
know the newly owed five million he says
he first of all the figure of five
million is uncertain but secondly he
says that it was carelessness now there
will be an inquiry but what you can't do
peers which is one of the reasons why I
was grunting here you can't blame Rishi
shunak either for what Boris did you
know who was two prime ministers ago uh
or if he's been misled by Sahara you
can't blame him for what some Tories are
saying now you can blame him for
dithering if if as it turns out he's
been misled already by Nadeem but that's
an if and you know there are processes
to be gone why have they changed their
position from what he said in the in the
House of Commons which is this matter is
basically it's all fine and done and
dusted next thing is all reopened again
we've got an investigation why would
that be necessary well first of all when
Richard shunak said that it was all done
and dusted what he was saying was that
this had been settled with hmrc now if
there was actual fraud involved if there
was deliberate non-disclosure for
example hmrc would have Sahari in the
courts but if you've got a chance of the
exchecker who is at the same time
negotiating with people who work for him
right over how much he should be fined
for non-payment of millions in tax I
like Nadeem zahawk as a person right but
I'm sorry he's thinking rich and he was
caught not paying millions in tax and he
was fine because of it but it may not
have been deliberate that is the point
that I'm reading and no no just a minute
Richard how did somebody get to be
chance of exchecker and not know they
are maybe because they're constant that
worries me because it's constant
and I'm so grateful and we're only
having this discussion because of the
tenacity and the indomitable Spirit of
the journalists who have absolutely you
wouldn't want him
this is not about honesty this is about
avoidance avoidance potentially of tax
and avoidance of the truth he could have
come out and answered the questions of
the journalist he chose not to what he
chose to do was to send a letter
threatening liable action okay I think
it's more simple than that you can't be
appointed to be in charge of the hmrc
when you know which he must have known
that he was in a significant debate
discussion dispute with hmrc it shows a
complete lack of integrity proprietary
and decency he should have said to Boris
Johnson the Prime Minister time prime
minister I can't accept this job because
I've still got some complications with
my Affairs the fact that he accepted
that job in that knowledge for me I
think if you misled Richard suneck and
it looks to me like he hasn't given him
the full picture hence the changing
position I'm counting it as if but what
we do know now is he got fined at least
a million we think uh for non-payment
for careless for everyone to dress it up
as but if it turns out he didn't give
the full story to his boss how can he
stay as party chairman he can't well he
can't he can't if but but actually yeah
exactly but if soon it was a was a
strong leader with real principles he
should have fired him by now he's
brought the government into disrepute
and sunak should have said that's it I'm
sorry you know you've got to go you're
bringing the government into decision
can you be a party chairman and be fined
a seven-figure sum it's a non-payment
attacks and you've also recently been
answer and and really legitimately
continue running the party I admit that
if I were in the hallways position now
even if I thought I had done no wrong at
all I would be saying to Richard shunak
look you know for the time being I've
just got to step aside okay Steve I want
to bring about Steve Hilton on this
because Steve if you were advising David
Cameron and this was the party chairman
of the day in Nadeem zahawi's position
would he still be there or would David
Cameron have forced him out by now on
your advice
I think uh he would have done and he
wouldn't have needed my advice to do it
because he was very aware
um that actually when you're in a
leadership position particularly in a
role like that where you're trying to
represent all of the interests of the
party
um on all policy matters you've got to
be someone who doesn't himself or
herself cause the problems that you're
trying to clean up and so I think he
would have got rid of him because of the
fact that this is still going on the
fact that all the answers haven't been
given I'm not following it as closely as
you all are but I think that's exactly
right and and even in in the few years
since Dave David Cameron was prime
minister there seems to be a real change
in this sense that people just cling on
whatever the situation to The Bitter End
rather than doing the decent thing and
not often if you do the decent thing you
can come back because people respect
you've done
right it's the persistent nature of
these things right so only in the last
week we've got the zahawi tax Scandal
for one of a better phrase you've got
the Prime Minister been called not
wearing a seat belt right it's pretty
good I know it's pretty low level but he
actually did get held to account for it
and so that's another ticket on his
record following the one he got for
breaking covers these things do matter
to some people and I think and then you
have the situation with the BBC chairman
Richard Sharp who gets that job as a
government appointee after facilitating
Boris Johnson getting this 800 Grand
loan from his distant cousin I mean you
put it all together and we don't know
the full facts about the two big bigger
things here but you put it all together
and it's just this constant sense of
loads of money being slushed around jobs
for the boys blah blah blah and it just
it just feels sleazy the perception for
the public you're all really on the
breadline right now millions of them is
that they're all in it for their own
gain and it's all sleazy
what's Boris to do with rashish unik
well originally was boris's Chancellor
for two years yeah but he wouldn't have
known about the loan would it says how
do you know is that what you're saying
no I'm not saying that at all I don't
know I don't know all I know all I know
are the facts we know that Richard Sharp
who's the chairman of the BBC we know
that he went to uh the cabinet secretary
and he facilitated a meeting with this
distant cousin of Boris to loan Boris
Johnson 800 000 quid because he was he
can't blame Russia for that I won't
blame him Rishi I'm just saying this has
happened as well well you're a lighting
thing well I'm aligning them all to one
party
but how can the chairman of the
conservative party lead any high moral
ground investigation or make any comment
about Boris Johnson and the chairman of
the BBC and Ms 800 Grand when he himself
is bedeviled by Scandal over not paying
Millions tell you what I would do if I
were into the hallway's position I've
already told you that yeah
you agree with me not entirely because I
think you're assuming guilt I don't know
I'm not assuming
purely on the facts
his position is difficult pure decency
and integrity would show the man should
resign and as Steve says he's just
Clinging On by every fingertip that he
can yeah to the role of chairman and to
the ordinary person on the street it
stinks talking of people who I I will
come back to people in a second bring in
Steve on this this character George
Santos who's a republican Congressman
one of my favorite stories in the world
right now so he's an absolute serial
liar well literally he doesn't even his
name isn't right he uses his pseudonyms
all over the place so I listed last week
in a New York Post column about 20
different things you've been caught
lying about including that his mother
died on 9 11 in the Twin Towers she
wasn't in the in the country at the time
and so on I mean despicable things he
pretends to be Jewish you know pretends
his parents struggled in the OR relative
struggle the Holocaust none of it is
true anyway the the classic happened I
wrote this column the very next day
there's a new allegation that he was a
drag queen in Brazil at carnival and he
gave an absolutely emphatic denial
absolutely untrue and guess what the
very next day out came the pictures of
my friend George Santos there he is
uh he's the big guy in the drag dress
there's George the serial liar and the
latest clip uh has him telling Rachel
Maddow of MSNBC that he survived an
assassination attempt I would say there
are two hopes of that being true no hope
and Bob Hope uh what do you make of him
Steve I mean how is he still in Congress
this guy every single thing he ever says
about himself from every school he went
to to University Records to sporting
records to his parentage do everything
to his ethnicity is all complete
bullcrap yeah
everything it is absolutely um it's
literally unbelievable each fact is
literally unbelievable that he puts out
there all turns out to be a lie and then
they just keep getting worse and he
keeps accumulating them there's another
the reason that he's Clinging On
um which is the theme of all of these
um and not taking responsibility is that
he is desperate to stay and his party is
so weak because they have a small
majority right in the House of
Representatives of five if he goes
that's down to four that's barely
anything it's tough enough for Kevin
McCarthy who's the leader of the
Republicans in the House of
Representatives to get anything done
with that tiny majority so it's raw
politics that's why he's still there but
again it's just causing this massive
embarrassment to the Republicans and
they won't make the tough call and say
look sorry this guy is ridiculous yeah
he's just he's just completely
embarrassing all of us he's got to go
but they won't because they don't want
to lose that seat because they fear that
if he goes the seat that he actually won
from the Democrats would return to the
Democrat rats and they have a slightly
smaller majority I mean it's terrible
well the trouble is that political
expediency on both sides of the pond is
now replacing political property and
personal property people just don't care
shamelessness is now the order of the
day it doesn't matter if you tell the
truth it doesn't matter what you get up
to you're just Brazen it out and if it
suits the party to keep you in the job
that's good enough and it's just it's
pathetic frankly uh Steve great to have
you on the program please come back
really enjoyed having you
good to see appears of course anytime
thank you very much good to see you Pat
you're staying so you'll be pleased to
know that
Sarah give me a smile you know you want
to
we'll be back after the break talking uh
serious matters Ukraine Boris Johnson
says what the hell are we waiting for
not talking about more details of on his
secret loans from his distant cousins
via the BBC Chairman's help he's talking
about sending tanks to Ukraine we'll
debate whether the West's sending help
will escalate the war perhaps bring it
to an end
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we'll still become the British shot put
Champion speaking out about transgender
athletes competing in female categories
she's not happy with good reason
but first the US is reportedly about to
send a significant number of Tanks to
Ukraine president zielinski is asking
for 300 modern battle tanks to continue
the defense of his territory there
aren't many things I agree with Boris
Johnson about but it starts on the war
in Ukraine is one of them after visiting
at the weekend the former prime minister
wrote look at these Brave ukrainians and
answer me this question just what the
hell are we waiting for sooner we can
help the ukrainians to their inevitable
Victory the sooner their suffering will
be over and the sooner the whole world
including Russia can begin to recover
from Putin's catastrophe well then what
the hell are we waiting for was aimed
chiefly at Germany there are 2 000
German manufactured leopard tanks across
Europe many of them unused tonight there
are reports that may send tanks but the
government's not yet confirmed this
Germany now as author and activist Bill
Browder also known as Putin's number one
enemy a badge I think he should wear
with honor and Fox Nation host Tommy
layer well welcome to both of you Bill
we're sort of it seems to me a pivotal
moment in this war a lot of the British
military writing in the last few days
that we should really ramp up our
support for Ukraine and try and get them
to a victory others worry that if we do
that uh what does defeat look like if
you're Vladimir Putin and what would you
do if you feel like you're losing
well first of all we need to understand
that there are only two outcomes to this
war either Russia wins which would be a
total and terrible disaster because
they'd be at Estonia next and then we'd
be fighting Russia directly or Ukraine
wins there is not going to be a
negotiated settlement in the middle are
we past that stage there never was a
stage of negotiation because Ukraine
won't give up an inch of territory and
they want the territory back that's been
taken and you should understand that
Putin if he were to show any sign of
weakness to the Russian people any
conciliation any compromise
um he would lose power and if Putin
loses power he goes to jail he loses his
money and he dies what about the risk
that some people have and some very
smart people have the if cornered and if
he really believes he's going to lose
and be humiliated probably lose his job
and his life that he might start playing
around with tactical nuclear weapons
well first of all I should point out
that there's no chance that he'll play
around with nuclear weapons sending them
to London or Germany or Washington he
understands full well that if he does
that there will be mutually assured
destruction that's the reason why nobody
has done nuclear what if he used a
tactical weapon on the battlefield
against Ukraine so what does that do for
him does he win the war with that no
um does he um all the Indians and
Chinese and South Africans and all these
people who are supporting him will
abandon him NATO is not going to sit
back and say okay you can just do
nuclear weapons they'll probably sink
the Black Sea Fleet turn off the
electricity grid by a whatever in Russia
and so Putin will have set off a nuclear
weapon alienated himself become more
isolated than North Korea and still not
won the war that would probably be the
end of Putin he understands okay Tommy
Laren I don't understand why any
rational human being would not want to
see Putin lose this war and Ukraine win
it just basically because if we if we
let Russia win where does this murderous
Barbarian stop
yeah I know and I understand that and I
think that the world would agree with
you on that point however as an American
I will say this we have our own border
to protect and there are a lot of
Americans myself included who are really
sick and tired of sending billions and
billions of dollars to Ukraine to prop
up their war effort we don't see an end
in sight now I understand your previous
guess and you discuss how yes there's
only two outcomes here well I think a
lot of Americans are hopeful that there
is a third outcome that there is some
kind of a the a process a diplomatic
process that can take place but I'll
tell you this well we've got 5 million
plus illegal immigrants surging our
Southern border we're really sick and
tired of fronting the Ukrainian War you
say that to me you're not ready to put
boots
okay but 57 of Americans support the war
in Ukraine 64 in a new you gov CBS poll
said they wanted their representatives
to support USA to Ukraine uh it looks to
me like the majority of Americans don't
agree with you actually they they want
to continue this because and I'm I'm
actually I've got to be honest with you
I am staggered to hear Republican voices
in America who who look at Vladimir
Putin the old enemy doing barbaric
things in Europe and don't think that
the right thing to do is to help Ukraine
win this War I don't understand why
Republicans have suddenly got soft on
dictators what's the matter with you
well I'll tell you this a lot of
Republicans have been hemorrhaging
millions and billions of dollars there
are a lot of Republicans that do want to
fund this war effort but there's a lot
of average Americans who are struggling
in this country who are sick and tired
of seeing our tax dollars go to front
that effort and I'll also tell you this
there are a lot of Americans myself
included who do not trust zielinsky we
believe in the Ukrainian cause we
believe in the Ukrainian people we do
not trust zielinski so there's a lot of
issues that a lot of Americans have we
would like to see Ukraine win this war
but at what cost and at what end and are
we ready to get involved I can tell you
this a lot of Americans are not
especially when we have the issues we
have at home especially when we have the
commander-in-chief the man in the white
house that we do this might be a
different story if we had Donald Trump
still in office I don't think we'd be in
this situation if Donald Trump was still
in office because Russia respected
Donald Trump did you support okay let me
ask the problem we're in right now did
you did you support the first Gulf War
well listen I'm 30 years old so I was
very young when that happens I don't
know if I could give you an answer that
you'd be looking for on that but I'll
tell you this logically did you think
that that was it was that right the
American forces Went to went to the aid
of a country that was not a member of
NATO and they kicked out Saddam Hussein
in that first Gulf War because
Republicans almost almost to a man and
woman supported that and thought that
was great Desert Storm and yet I don't
see the difference other than Putin is
exceptionally more dangerous than Saddam
Hussein ever was and represents a much
bigger threat to the world that I would
argue that Saddam Hussein did and yet
Republicans back in 91 they were like
yeah let's get in there and kick him out
now it's like a few Republicans are
going why are we spending all this money
on taking on a dictator and I'm like
what's the matter with you
foreign
I'll tell you this there's a lot of
Americans out there that have learned
our lesson from fronting endless Wars
and we're sick and tired of it if you
look at our history there have been many
mistakes that we have made Iraq
Afghanistan this nation-building effort
there's a lot here at home we need to
work on like I said we would like to see
the Ukrainian people pull this out we
are however not entirely confident that
they're able to do it without endless
support endless money endless help from
Nations like the United States and I'll
tell you a lot of Americans are not in
the position to be sending billions more
to zelinski we don't trust Solinski we
have a lot of questions okay and this is
not about supporting Putin over Ukraine
make no mistake we also Republicans did
not support trading a Russian arms
dealer back to Russia for a weed smoking
basketball player but then again a lot
of Democrats cheered for that one all
right let me I'll just want to play I
want to go to Bill's responses okay I
hear you I want to play this is from
when I went to see president zielinski
in cave in Ukraine uh in the summer last
year and I asked him about about this
resistance from some Americans who
they're all people in America uh some on
the Republican side in particular who
think that America shouldn't be spending
all this money on a wall here which has
nothing to do with them they think there
are more important things in America
like inflation and so on that they
should be working on what is your
message to those Americans who do not
think Americans should be as heavily
involved
absolutely we are fighting for
absolutely communal values that are
universally understood
some time ago I responded that war
doesn't have a distance and the war in
Ukraine is still the war against those
values that are professed in the United
States and in Europe so this war here
and now in Ukraine and forgive me I'm
saying it's so cynically it's for the
safety of Europe as long as we are
resisting the Integrity of the United
States will continue therefore
we are giving our lives for your values
and the joint security of the world
you know Bill I I found him incredibly
impressive I don't share Tommy's view of
zelenski which is which is a view that
some Americans have of him uh I don't I
think he's an incredibly impressive guy
who is that single-handedly galvanized
his country to at least believe they can
withstand the the invading hordes of of
Putin's Army but to that point what
would you say to Tommy to try and
persuade her that this is money well
spent by America well it's pretty
straightforward so um first of all I'm
58 years old not 30 years old so I've
known Putin for 22 years he's an
absolute criminal he's a murderous
dictator and the reason he started this
war is to um basically as a war of
distraction Wag the Dog he's trying to
people after 22 years are sick and tired
of Putin he doesn't want them angry with
him so he creates a foreign enemy so
he's got to be at this war he's doing
this war to stay in power and the one
thing I can tell you is that if he were
to win in Ukraine he would next be at
the Estonian board yeah no question and
and if he's at the Estonian border then
we're faced with the most horrible
outcome either we have to go to war
directly with Vladimir Putin which would
be a terrible thing or we would have to
abandon our NATO allies and we learned
surely in 1939 with without all settler
we learned that people like Hitler
people like Putin they don't stop they
prey on weakness they they want to call
our Bluff they want to Rattle their
saber and hope that we give them what
they want that's what dictators do
Putin absolutely enjoys the fact that
we're all sort of arguing among
ourselves but I should also point out
that the view that she was expressing is
an extreme minority view I work with
Republicans and Democrats in Washington
and the vast vast majority of
Republicans understand that it's an
America's national security interest not
to have Putin take over the Earth okay
well let me final words that some of you
you're an extreme minority
hahaha
yeah maybe in the DC Beltway and the
people that you're talking to in the
swamp but average everyday Americans out
there who can't even find eggs in baby
formula and worrying about inflation and
worrying about crime in our streets
worrying about illegal immigration at
our border I represent those Americans
and those Americans are not an extreme
minority those Americans believe in
America first and I agree with you Putin
is a horrible person we don't want Putin
to take over the world but I'll tell you
this I don't I'm not sure that us
sending more money more tanks to upfront
this Ukraine war effort is going to stop
Putin unless we are ready to directly go
to war with Putin I think a lot of
Americans are going to be in that boat
and in that case all right Tommy you've
made your point loud and clear and very
well for an extreme minority I must say
uh good to have on the program Bill
Bradley great to have you here in the
studio thank you very much indeed thank
you well Kevin as I talked to the
champion female shot Putters of the
trans athletes compete in her sport then
she's screwed so screwed in fact she
might have to retire
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
well welcome back you know my general
view that the world's gone completely
crackers well there was a brilliant
piece written in today's Daily Telegraph
by trans athlete Tina Daniels who says
she considered entering events in 2012
London Olympics after undergoing gender
realignment surgery from a man to a
woman I could have won Gold in every
category but she wrote this was
something I couldn't bring myself to do
while others have worked tirelessly for
the chance to realize that same dream
because of my unfair Advantage I would
just be taking a deserved spot away
it's fairness that my next guest is
concerned about today what Athletics is
looking at increasing restrictions on
trans women but not Banning them
completely from women's sport and
British shot put Champion Amelia
strickler says it could screw women in
her sport her words in her own excellent
piece about this and Amelia you join me
now so I better explain to you as why
you sound a little bit American you're
born in Ohio yeah you're British
American you compete for for Britain
yeah you've been a British champion and
shot put him twice and you'll hopefully
will be competing for GB in the Olympics
the next one yes
talk to me about this issue because I've
been talking about this as a man for a
long time yeah but in the end I think
there's a debate that has to be won by
women
it seems to me just grotesquely unfair
that you can reduce testosterone as much
as you like but what you can't reduce
and Caitlyn Jenner is very strong about
this you can't reduce physical size
power body mass all the things you
accumulate in a male body for many years
is that really at the heart of this yeah
um ultimately you know the hormones are
not going to take away that male
Advantage the hormone suppressors or
um yeah it's just it's not going to it's
not going to take away that male puberty
you know there are physiological things
you can't change skeleton sizes hip
angles lung capacities you know
obviously the muscle and some people you
know transition later in life don't they
so they may have trained
as a man for many many years biological
male right and then all of a sudden
decided to identify and the common theme
if you take Leah Thomas a swim in
America or you take some of the
sprinters in Connecticut will be
smashing women's records uh or Laurel
hubbardies in New Zealand uh
weightlifter who transitioned and
competes against women the common theme
is that as male performers they were
pretty mediocre but when they start
competing against women having
transitioned and said I'm now
identifying as female they start
smashing records which may never be
beaten in some cases I mean they're
basically rewriting women's sport
exactly and they're taking away a lot of
opportunities from other women that have
worked so hard to be where they are
um Leah Thomas winning the national
title
you know they were they were never good
enough to do that in the in the mail
category now we're near good enough and
you know it's it's really about keeping
women's sport Fair where's he gonna go
this I mean if if what Athletics are
going to be so gutless as they currently
being where they're just basically
sitting on the fence and hoping this all
blows over it's not going to blow over
because more and more people are now
identifying as a different gender this
has become a huge phenomenon now around
the world which means more and more
athletes are going to be transitioning
and saying okay now I'm a woman now what
happens if you are a high performing
male athlete in any discipline and you
see an opportunity if you're cynical we
know there are cheats in sport right we
saw it of course from Lance Armstrong to
others and they go you know what here's
a way for me to make myself extremely
rich and famous I just put my hand up
say I'm female for three years win
everything's earn hundreds of millions
and go back to being a man at the end of
it exactly what's the top of someone
doing that it's happening at Grassroots
level as well already
um you know that's even if it's just a
park run surely that means something to
someone to place you know high enough
yeah and you know they'll never have
they'll never have periods they'll never
experience that you know it it does
hinder many many females yes females
it's a real issue even you know Dino
this summer said you know I've had lady
issues and she didn't perform well when
she didn't perform well that day and you
know it's understandable what reaction
have you had since you wrote this piece
and went public it was a brave thing to
do I've had very good reactions I've had
a lot of people say you know thank you
from me thank you from my daughter
um you know this this this means a lot
so much to so many you know women and
and men and you know everyone seems to
have have a really positive reaction to
it um obviously any negativity of course
you're gonna have some um you know some
want to say I'm not even British but
right so they start being racist yeah
exactly and they and you've been accused
of being transferred which is the
default position for anyone that dares
to raise concerns about this issue you
have to be a transphobe even though
you're not a transfer at all right no I
I fully think they should be included
but there's a way to have them be
included and not have it harm female
Sport and biological females competing
in the in sport you know swimming they
did an open category and a female
category to protect the female sex and
to protect
athletes to have a trans category and
just build that up and just have a third
you know but why not I mean yeah what
what's happening in a moment is just not
fair it's not fair to work and women's
rights are being eroded at the altar of
political correctness that's all that's
happening and people are terrified of
saying this is wrong that's why I really
wanted to get you in and I really admire
you for what you've done it's a it's a
really bold thing have you heard from
the British athletic bosses or not I
have not but a lot of other big names my
peers you know people I'm on teams with
big names people that people would know
these names they agree with you strongly
support me but obviously I think you
know people are scared to speak out they
do not want the label of transphobic
they do not want their contracts to
potentially be in Jeopardy which I can
understand Athletics is not a wealthy
sport we're not making football money
um but you know it is important to me
and you must have known when he wrote
this piece that this could fire horribly
it might be the end of your career yeah
I mean that's a that literally
anything could have happened to you it
did cross my mind um but I am so
grateful for everyone who's reached out
positively because it really is touching
to hear that you know someone's daughter
is looking up to me just for speaking up
I didn't expect
good for you we need more people with
your guts to do this then then this
debate can be had properly and fairly
because nobody wants to be unfair to
trans athletes but I don't think they
should be allowed to just dominate
women's sport which is incredibly unfair
to women born to female bodies just
barely just simple period but it is full
stop as people say in this country and
while I'm turning all American then
inappropriate there
um finally one question for you what
makes you wake up one day and think I
know what I'm going to do with myself
I'm going to run along and Chuck an
eight pound weight 18 meters
um this is what you do yes I I was young
and got involved in athletics and you
know I loved I loved all the events but
this one this one I seem to excel at and
I just stuck with it and it's been quite
a journey and you know it still makes me
happy whatever amazing I think it's an
amazing thing to watch it really is it's
so hard to actually move and then throw
something that far that weighs eight
pounds it's just a I could I couldn't
throw it out of the pitbit
Amelia you're very gutsy keep speaking
out uh others will follow you but as
always it takes the first people over
the top to just to call it for what it
is and you've done that so thank you
very much thank you thank you so much I
hope I do hope more people speak yeah
because it's very important this has to
get addressed properly yeah and best of
luck see you at the Olympics yeah we
need people you all kind of guts at the
Olympics that's what it takes a bit of
mental strength courage resilience don't
take this nonsense if you can take down
the wokies you can certainly win Olympic
gold I'm right behind you Amelia I hope
so good to see you thank you well coming
next will the scandals evolving prince
Andrew and Harry and Megan overshadow
King Charles's coronation do you know
that any of them be invited we'll debate
that next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
well back with my pack now following our
earlier debate about Ukraine it's a very
sad breaking news it's just been
confirmed that two British men who were
volunteering in Ukraine Chris parry and
Andrew Bagshaw had been killed they're
reported missing in January Mr parry's
family confirmed tonight they were both
killed while assisting a humanitarian
evacuation and if that doesn't toughen
our resolve in this country to do
whatever we can to help Ukraine win that
War I don't know what would
well coming next I'm joined now by the
Titans Royal correspondent and author of
Portia is the hidden power behind the
crown Valentine low plus our pack is
still here and what it could Richard
Tyson poor own Adrian so Valentine
you're over in America at the moment
um with uh promoting your book
fascinating piece in the New York Times
has just come out headlines has Prince
Harry's confessional tour run its course
even in the United States the New York
Times says which has a high tolerance
for Redemptive stories about overcoming
trauma and family dysfunction the tide
seems to be turning it's one thing to be
criticized it's another to be openly
ridiculed that's pretty heavy coming
from the New York Times
it is because they would be very much on
the Harry and Megan's side but one does
sense that well there's still you know
quite a strong Bedrock have been in
favor of them that they are less popular
uh than they were over here and you know
there is so much moaning that you can
put up with isn't it right I I
completely agree I mean how do you keep
doing it where is it where can they go
they've trashed all their family
repeatedly there's no one left to trash
um what about prince Andrew what impact
is all his scandal having does it really
resonate in America in the same way even
though it arguably is a lot more serious
uh I don't think it does quite in the
same way because it's it's sort of not
really an ongoing soap opera is it the
good thing about Harry and Megan is
there's there's such a strong narrative
drive there isn't it to keep everyone
interested whereas Andrew he's he's just
a mess who messed up uh and sort of
covered himself and the family in shame
but it it doesn't really go anywhere do
you think either Robin Valentine will be
at the coronation either prince Andrew
or Harry Megan
I I suspect prince Andrew will be I
think uh the king will invite him and
and he if invited he'll definitely be
there I think in terms of Harry and
Megan I think they'll certainly be
invited uh because uh for for King
Charles not to invite his son would
really be seen as sort of petty and and
vindictive uh and not in the spirit of I
wouldn't invite one of my sons if they'd
done that to the family I can tell you
they'd be absolutely NFI
um well you're not King that's why
you're not King yes well at the moment
at the moment Valentine at the moment
stranger things have happened
um Richard the Royals the coronation it
remains it is a soap opera but they're
real people uh we're we're hurtling
towards the coronation in a few weeks
time in early May what's he going to do
Charles about his brother now in the
headlines again because of the Gilley
Maxwell uh interview with Harry and
Megan his son in a trashing it's very
easy he has to retain the moral High
Ground of course he has to invite all
his family whether or not they attend I
suspect uh the Valentine's right I don't
think Harry and Megan will attend I
think backdoor channels will say please
stay in and invite them I mean because
because you've you've got to you've got
to retain the moral Eiger and you're
King you're bringing people together
you're leading from the front a whole
nation and just don't stir the pot
um whereas I suspect prince Andrew I
suspect he will attend and be sort of
stuck on the back row Paula the resident
defender of all things Megan and Harry I
mean why if they hate the royal family
and the monarchy so much and trash the
institutions
whatever you want to call stop saying
the word hate no one has suggested that
hate is relevant in this issue given
they've caused so much damage to the
institutional reputation of the monarchy
why would they want to be a coronation
of a new monarch given the fact that
they have raised difficulties that they
have had well they said the rules and
races then said we didn't mean that's
what we're talking about the problems
that they have raised let's be clear
about all the life and the problems I
have raised are really seriously mental
health issues issues
issues around why do you believe that
and Prejudice why do you believe that
but it's not about whether I believe
them why it's not about that without any
proof what it's about is that they think
it's true and what you need to
understand is
nothing to do with whether they think
it's true either true or it's not thank
you
or not if that was the case then I
wouldn't be in a job what fact is your
truth may not be my truth
and it will be very different to all of
us that doesn't mean Hello I know and
I'm choosing to ignore my show that's my
show and I'll cut off your mic in a
minute uh here's the bottom line there
is no my truth your truth
and you know what really got my goat
about those two was the two most
damaging things they said in that first
Oprah winathon where the the Royals have
been racist to them about the skin color
of their of their son and secondly uh
Meghan Markle had gone to a senior
Palace person who had banned her from
getting help for her Suicidal Thoughts
neither of those things appear in his
book
he's already reigned back now on the
racism charge so that's not what he
meant when we all knows exactly what
they meant they said it we watched them
say it and secondly Richard on the
mental health thing again a very big
weapon to hurl at the palace that they
were callous about her Suicidal Thoughts
not a word has been mentioned since
nothing in the Netflix documentary
nothing in the book I don't think it
happened Harry and I had to leave my
last job but not believing it how can
Harry have therapy exactly but she not
have therapy she had a therapy little
speed dial unless he didn't he did
unless he didn't think that she deserved
it I mean the whole thing's a complete
nonsense you can't the question you just
couldn't trust anything up though didn't
she when she said
um at that memories
and so no and so what happens is when
you have a situation where somebody is
in pain where you say something that you
do not consider to be insulting will you
do not consider to be hurtful or in any
way intentional even but that doesn't
mean that the other person doesn't take
it that way that doesn't mean that the
other person does that discussion
we're talking about them going on Oprah
Winfrey and calling the royal family
racists and then two years later after
all the damage of that race charge
against the royal family and they never
named the racist Harry now says we
didn't say anyone was racist the evil
British press who are responsible for
everything in Harry's World
he's technically right they didn't say
that
he's a decision
that's a different topic that's the same
topic was there a Nuance there that
people were led to believe that have you
always defended offensive or was it a
new trait of yours
yes what do we do about the Royals well
first of all I do not think that Harry
and Megan should be at the corner for
one very simple reasons
if they're there they then become the
story and they'll be taping everybody
and heaven knows you know private
conversations the rules will be very
uneasy so I do not think they should
come to the coronation I don't think it
matters whether Andrew's there or not
because I rather think that he also you
know he will just be in the background
and there'll be a comment I agree he
won't try and take the attention he's
not going to take all the cameras I
wouldn't trust if I were the royal
family I wouldn't trust the sussexes as
far as I could what appears
it takes you don't get reconciliation
releasing a 410 page book trash in your
family he's not the first one to release
an autopilot oh let me run out of time
the first but you know what we can
continue this you can come back again
because I I like the new Paula
irritating but I quite like it
great to see you truth is objective
the truth is
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]